so if you want to measure intelligence
you need to rigorously define what
intelligence is which in itself units
it's a very challenging problem
I think intelligence is essentially the
efficiency with which you turn
experience into generalizable programs
so what that means is it's the
efficiency with which you turn a
sampling of experience base into the
ability to process a larger chunk of
experience base measuring intelligence
in humans is difficult enough surely
here is trying to come up with a measure
in machines and that's a pretty daunting
task and although I don't agree with him
on some of what he says and proposes and
whether or not that's a good thing I
believe that the paper is pretty fun and
the formalism at least holds in my view
and the ark challenge is to me the most
interesting part because even though I
don't think it's gonna get us anywhere
to AI it's a fun challenge and it's a
nice deviation from standard machine
learning and standard cattle challenges
intelligence emerges from the
interaction between a train a body and
polite intelligence and in environment
welcome back to the machine learning
Street talk YouTube channel and podcast
today is francois chalet
Francois was a huge inspiration for me
personally and Yannick and Connor and I
have all covered his measure of
intelligence paper on our respective
YouTube channels and now it's time for
us to do a deep dive into some of the
ideas that Francois relay has Chalet is
one of the most credible critics of deep
learning
he argues that at best deep learning
algorithms are just interpolating
between the input space that all they do
is learn a geometric morphing from X to
Y and only were given a sufficiently
dense sampling of X to Y there is no
extrapolation there is no extreme
generalize a
and given a few examples it's impossible
for deep learning algorithms to
generalize in the way that we generalize
he would go on to argue in a further
sense that deep learning algorithms
learn shortcuts they learn surface
shortcuts and that they don't learn the
kind of rules that we would learn in
respect of the same task there have been
some incredible successes with deep
learning recently and essentially we've
been throwing more and more data more
and more computes more and more
architecture and these models are
incredible but we shouldn't make the
mistake of thinking that they are
reasoning this is Sholay's argument what
these models are doing at best is the
imitation of reasoning they are taking
shortcuts and it's so easy to take
shortcuts when you have these highly
parametric models that are learning a
geometric morphing in a continuous space
there are so many shortcuts that these
models can take chalette pointed out
that these deep neural networks perform
this series of geometric transformations
mapping data from one manifold into
another manifold successively of course
assuming that there exists a continuous
learn about transformation from X to Y
in order for that to work chalette
points out that you need to have a dense
sampling of X to Y so you can think of
deep learning models as being kind of
like computer programs but the inverse
is not true deep learning models cannot
represent most computer programs the
reason for that is the corresponding
geometric transformation may just be too
complicated or there might not be enough
data available that's in the future
we're going to have national models that
look much more like computer programs
like the sort of programs that you might
be familiar with Xu Lai is arguing for a
complete change in direction he's
advocating strongly for program
synthesis some kind of a meta learning
algorithm which would produce a skilled
program which could generalize to a far
greater number of examples we have no
way to quantify generalization to 25f
structure
so I think there is a need for an
ambitious new benchmark that that will
be focused on measuring precisely
generalization capabilities right
generation strength and not just skill
at a specific task given sufficient
training data which is not very
interesting
so you could think of it as a sort of an
IQ test that would be applicable to
measuring algorithms but also to humans
ideally so that we could compare the
capabilities are for creations with the
capabilities of humans you could call it
a GQ test the generalization quotient so
what then is a real display of
intelligence in chalets framework
intelligence is something that your
priors and your experiences do not
prepare you for in chalets framework if
you have a problem that's this hard and
your prior knowledge and all your
experience today only get you this far
the difference is what you have to use
intelligence for and therefore if we
measure intelligence we should look at
all of these quantities we should look
at how hard is the task and to which
part can your prior experience and also
your data that you have collected so far
helped you in solving the task whatever
is left that's intelligence shall I
cites the example of a sorting algorithm
with a few lines of code you can write a
sorting algorithm which would generalize
analytically to any permutation of
numbers for a deep learning model to do
the same thing it would need to have a
dense sampling arguably of every single
permutation of numbers
shall I points out that previous
conceptions of intelligence were based
on expert systems and knowledge if only
we could encode human behavior as
logical predicate and if only we could
encode human knowledge using databases
and knowledge graphs then we would solve
intelligence machine learning came along
and it changed the game significantly it
started to become about learning but not
only learning shall a word argue that
the most important concept is
generalization and when we solve
generalization when we can have an
intelligence that can produce a skill
program
which generalizes then we've solved
artificial general intelligence first
definition of generalization presented
in the paper is the difference between
system centric generalization and
developer aware generalization so I
think it's useful to think about this in
the context of known cross unknowns with
respect to these novel encounters that
we're going to expect our system to face
one of the key contributions from shala
in this paper is the ark challenge and
Kangol competition it's essentially an
IQ test but with a much higher diversity
of tasks and none of the tasks have been
procedurally generated from a static
master program which makes them harder
to reverse-engineer and you have to
create skilled programs that generalize
from just three examples of these tasks
deep learning methods are not applicable
one of the key reasons that chalette
introduced the ark challenge was to
demonstrate developer aware
generalization as a developer you need
to create a solution to this which will
work on a task that you can never seen
before
chale also argues in stark contrast to
leg and hutter
that there is no universal intelligence
he believes that we should have an
anthropocentric view of intelligence and
the artificial general intelligence that
we create should be able to perform the
same sorts of tasks as humans and we
should imbue the same sort of core
knowledge that humans have into these
algorithms so they makes a difference
between prior skill experience and
intelligence in this case probably
evolution has endowed me with the
ability to plan my way through any
uncomfortable terrain so shalay says
that might not necessarily be
intelligent because it's already built
into you so to be clear it is very good
at pattern recognition and I'm not in
any way trying to downplay the
significance of being good at pattern
recognition this is actually immensely
useful deplaning is pickable to a
tremendous scope of very difficult and
important problems in mission perception
because they are pattern recognition
problems at heart
but importantly deep learning is not the
road to artificial general intelligence
right scanning app deep learning by
adding more layers adding architectural
search
using you know as these deeper models
authoring on more data is not going to
get you to HDI social I thinks that we
should create a meta learning algorithm
that could create the kind of high-level
rules and reasoning that humans would in
respect at the same task
Francois gelée retweeted me Bing I was
over the moon there was a real passion
project for me so I thoroughly recommend
to go and check out the feature-length
video on the measure of intelligence on
machine learning dojo make sure you also
check out Connor and Yannick made their
own videos about it
Yannick is actually planning a four part
series so the first part has gone out
and after we release this I think
Yannick is going to release the
subsequent part so keep an eye out for
that remember to Like comment and
subscribe we love reading your comments
and we're going to be back for a very
special episode with the team from
Facebook who wrote the transcoder paper
this is the neural network that can
translate from one language to another
language it's incredibly exciting and
we've got the entire team from Facebook
joining us next week so I hope you join
us for that
peace out I hope you enjoyed this
conversation we're trying to make sense
of all of this which is a huge topic
leave us your comments and suggestions
and all of that hello folks and welcome
back to the machine learning Street Talk
YouTube channel with me Tim scarf my two
compadres Yannick Kilcher and Connor
shorten that we are going to talk about
francois chalet on the measure of
intelligence this is a really
interesting paper francois seems to
think that current machine learning
methods are brittle and
data hungry they don't generalize very
well either from the training data that
they were trained with or from the
assumptions of their creators that they
can't really deal with novel tasks and
there's been a real focus on narrow
based skill as opposed to generalization
he thinks that we need to have an
actionable measure of intelligence but
he thinks that a lot of the skill based
methods now can be bought you know but
just by throwing lots of computation at
the problem and I would say francois is
probably one of the most popular a
critics of deep learning what do you
guys think about the paper
he's mainly concerned with intelligence
right so it's not it's not that much
criticism of deep learning but it is a
criticism of people who call deep
learning systems intelligent which is
prevalent today because the entire field
is somewhat nicknamed AI we'd much
rather define it as machine learning but
in the popular literature this is known
as AI and I think that's where the
criticism comes from the fact that
Sholay says maybe these things have not
really much to do with intelligence yeah
I think it's interesting that levels of
generalization talking about local and
broad generalization how the lines get
blurred between going from local
generalization which could be something
as like is it robust to adding a noise
map down to can you rotate the image or
you know perturb a single word in the
text classification tasks up to a broad
generalization where it's things like if
we're doing cats versus dogs and we add
a new dog breed how does it react to
that and a lot of the things I think
interesting this idea of system centric
verse developer where generalization is
kind of criticism of superglue favoring
the animal AI benchmark I thought was
interesting as well and the discussion
of the chess playing program that beats
Garry Kasparov and then it's no longer
intelligent and then he compares that to
alphago and alpha zero but I think mu
zero is actually something that's very
applicable to things like robotics and
even talking with Harry about
model-based reinforcement I think the
Museo algorithm is generally applicable
so excited to talk about that but I
think it's totally different the if/else
chess algorithm and then this
model-based new zero algorithm yeah but
what I'd love to get into that I think
in the beginning of the paper
Francois talks about the history leading
up to that and he says that we started
with expert systems and there was this
guy Minsky who had this conception of
intelligence which was based on it just
being a collection of the skills or
being able to perform certain tasks very
well and they didn't really have the
concept of generalization and if they
did have the concept of generalization
back then they felt that it was just
solved by
adding more knowledge to your knowledge
graph it was only really when machine
learning approaches came along in the
1980s that the word learning and the the
conception of generalization as a
first-class citizen was really discussed
surely goes on this whole 360 here where
he starts off by saying that you know
measuring skill is not really the same
as measuring intelligence if a system is
good at one particular task it doesn't
mean it's necessarily intelligent and he
says like yeah people thought once we
could solve chess that required
intelligence and so on he goes through
this whole thing to come back to the orc
challenge which is basically here's a
bunch of tasks if you solve them well
I'm gonna think your system is
intelligent right so it's important to
point out that I think this doesn't
really shine through in the paper is the
only thing we can measure is skill
that's the entire problem right we the
only thing we can really assess is how
well you do at a particular task
compared to some other system and I
think the whole paper if you read you
have to almost read it in the light of
how do we come up with sort of the
perfect task that we can measure skill
but that still gives us a good
indication of intelligence or
generalization capability what he what
he frames as intelligence is basically
generalization capability right this
g-factor idea is really interesting
trying to find like the common tasks
that all these different tasks like
Rubik's Cube solver may silver write a
poem get all do this one g-factor
hierarchy of cognition I really like the
physical fitness analogy my where he
says the marathon runner the bench
presser and the basketball player they
all have this common like lung capacity
thing at the top so you can try to do
that out so what do you think about that
kind of like like my take on that was
that there's like this catastrophic
forgetting phenomenon where it's like a
model that gets really good at
classifying imagenet would forget to do
this G factor task yeah you mean like a
model that can the more the more you
specialize on a particular task if you
do it in a machine learning way the
model would actually forget how to do
the other tasks is that
that's this catastrophic we're getting
right like I think catastrophic
forgetting is unlikely to follow this
higher might maintain the specialized
skills and forget the general thing is
so I think that would be the key
challenge to finding this generalizable
task the input-output measure that it
can all do this one task yeah exactly I
one of the kind of controversial things
that Chalet says and we'll get into this
in more detail that there was leg and
hütter in at 2007 I think they wrote a
paper which was formalizing a definition
of general intelligence and it was
completely different from chalets
conception and chalet explicitly says
that he doesn't like what leg and hütter
came up with but leg and hunters
definition is what's being taught in
universities now if you look at the
latest deeper mind set of lectures they
were teaching it in UCL just a few weeks
ago and they were teaching leg and Hutus
definition and we'll get to that but
Chalet thinks that intelligence should
be anthropocentric so it should be very
human focused and coming back to what
you were saying Condor about the
physical fitness level I think that's
super interesting he says the physical
fitness level is a bit like a latent
variable it's a constellation and
interdependent factors it's based on
what your lung capacity is how long your
legs are and various other
characteristics that you have and
intelligence is a bit like that as well
and there are many factors that
correlate with your general intelligence
well I had someone I I had someone I
think you know I don't remember if it
was on reddit or on a youtube comment
that took a lot of issue with this G
factor notion but I mean the surprising
thing about human intelligence testing
is that if you do the statistical
analysis the the model that explains
best how the humans perform on different
tasks is a model with one shared factor
right he could have come out very
differently for example personality
tests are best explained by five factors
or you can I guess subdivide those into
into ten factors but intelligence
appears to be best described by a single
factor and that's something that's I I
believe
is very surprising that's not just I
mean this hierarchy that that Chalet
says that you have this common
intelligence thing and then that's not
obvious it's not this the world didn't
have to come out like this right but it
appears that humans have this general
intelligence factor and that motivates
the entire thing so I believe that also
justifies to say that an intelligence
measure should be human centric because
human intelligence is the only
intelligence we know it doesn't surprise
me that there is a general quotient of
intelligence because all of the human
cognitive tasks that we perform have an
interdependency on sub-skills for
example if you have a poor working
memory that would negatively affect your
performance across a wide array of tasks
so it doesn't really come as a surprise
to me but you could imagine you know
there being two different kinds of
intelligence right so you could imagine
saying like this person is very good at
intelligence a that means very good at I
don't know these kinds of tasks and that
other human is very good at these kind
now that's true in general if you just
consider tasks but if you consider
cognitive tasks tasks that we would
include in IQ tests then you don't find
this split you don't find these two
independent directions or three or four
you find one single direction and that I
mean you can say yeah okay but it's not
entirely obvious from the start there
could be more I suppose one of
Schiller's justifications here for
placing a scope on different tasks is
that if you look at all of the possible
tasks that could exist in the universe
it's not really very meaningful yeah of
course I mean it's to me to me it's
fairly obvious that you should make an
intelligence especially if you go for
you know building an AI that sort of is
compared to humans that you should go
for a human measure of intelligence
indeed so
Shirley thinks that garry kasparov was
intelligent because he quickly learned
generalizable skill programs so it's not
that he's good at playing chess now it's
that he had the capability to learn it
quickly
Shirley argues that modern machine
learning is skill orientated in in this
setting I characterized Sholay as saying
he thinks that deep learning techniques
are glorified hash tables and I
personally think that is a fair
characterization based on what shall
they said but it's a little bit of
hyperbolic so I'm sorry about that he
thinks that that skill can be bought
with unlimited priors and training data
he introduces different types of
generalization so he formalizes levels
of generalization I think he has a bit
of a go at some of the recent moon shots
in AI so for example alphago he thinks
that we're barking up the wrong tree
essentially and that we're still focused
on skill based and learning as opposed
to learning something that can
generalize of course the folks that deep
mind would argue that their system can
generalize and it learns the rules of
the game as part of the training process
right but if you even change the board
size by one you would have to retrain
the entire algorithm from scratch so you
could argue that that isn't really an
indicative of generalization at all but
surely also argues that all intelligence
is relative to the scope of the
application
he thinks that AI should be benchmarked
against human intelligence so that there
should be an anthropocentric scope of
tasks when we measure intelligence and
by extension he thinks there is no such
thing as universal intelligence or that
we shouldn't be in thinking about
universal intelligence he also thinks
that and human-like general intelligence
should be founded on explicitly
described knowledge priors so there are
certain things that humans understand
like we know what dogs are and we know
what cats are and what arrows mean and
what ladders mean and so on so he thinks
that if we were to create any artificial
general intelligence algorithms that
that core knowledge should be imputed
into the algorithm there are lots of
things here so first of all I have some
kind of different opinions then surely
on these kinds of things and
so in some of these things he tries to
make it very formal but I feel that he
sort of it's it's kind of made up like
these different levels of generalization
okay so you can say okay skill based
generalization is something we can we
can measure but after that it sort of
gets washy right and it's sort of it's
sort of you taking the point of view of
a human right now that looks at deep
learning and says what can deep learning
do okay this we're gonna call this skill
based generalization or narrow
generalization and what can't deep
learning do yet and we're going to call
that broad generalization right I feel
it's a very 2019 2020 view of the world
I feel it's less formal than he writes
it it's it's more washee-washee the same
with his notion of system centric
generalization and developer aware
generalization it makes sense to say
that you should consider generalization
in light of all the information that
went into a system which includes the
human programmer right so you should
take the human programmer of a system
into account but I mean by extension you
should also take into account the
programmer of the human programmer which
are the humans parents or you know the
culture around the human or the
evolutionary process that made the human
and if you go back then everything is as
generalizable as everything else because
everything came from the Big Bang and if
we really really capture developer aware
generalization in a broad manner we
would include the process of the Big
Bang and so I yeah these these things I
sort of have an issue with with that
they appear to be less formal than
they're stated and then the last thing I
just thought of is this alphago you know
saying that okay because alphago doesn't
generalize to other tasks and sort of
you can buy the scale at go by throwing
lots of resources at it and that's not
intelligent I sort of take a different
measure in that a human by itself could
not learn in this amount of time how to
play go this well right but and may may
be a machine by itself without a
programmer cannot either but the human
machine combination if I buy deep mind
right now right should if I buy deep
mind with all the people that thing is
incredibly intelligent as a
human-computer interaction module right
it can learn faster it can generalize to
new tasks so extremely fast not only
because it has the humans or the
machines but precisely because of the
combination of both right so the system
can generalize extremely well I wouldn't
see alphago as a failure necessarily
because we thought go was about ten
years out and they demonstrated no no no
you can learn it much faster and that
very much fits Shirley's definition of
intelligence that does a rapid
generalization to a new task yeah when
Lex Friedman interviewed david silva he
said something really interesting he
said that the cannon of go knowledge
wasn't created by one human being it was
created by many many people playing go
over thousands of years and alphago
discovered some new strategies that
weren't previously known and now humans
have started to incorporate those
strategies so i I love this notion and
chalette points this out that many
things that we don't think of as being
intelligent especially collective
entities you know things like markets or
companies or even science as a process
that they are intelligent but we don't
necessarily recognize them as being safe
but this is another thing that surely
argues for though is that the
information efficiency of acquiring
skills is important it seems quite
wasteful to brute-force search all of
the possible situations in the future in
order to derive a strategy and to learn
something well maybe I mean
it I see I mean I see what he means but
alphago figured out a way around this
right the tree search is too expensive
in go even in chess even in deep blue
the tree search was too expensive so you
had to heuristic it up and do whatever
the your min max search and whatnot and
and that's and that that's not the same
thing as brute forcing it and that is a
rapid generalization to this new task of
the human computer system well that's
another one of our favorite topics
raised like the policy network is the
system one thing in the Monte Carlo tree
search is our system two reasoning in
but like so really quick I want to stay
on this idea of local and broad
generalization and the system aware and
develop oh so this paper Durham Gann its
harvesting the generalization power of
generative models to diversify the data
set and then enhance the classifier so
sorry to our viewers if these pictures
are a bit too much for but so if these
skin classification pictures so you take
these semantic masts and you can move
around the location of the you know the
mole that you're in question the
lighting conditions the skin color so we
can use these generative models to
expand our scope of var known unknown so
we know that there's going to be the
lighting and the location of the mole
and so we can use these generative
models to augment those data sets and
then we also have these world models so
this game can thing is pretty
interesting to me they put this whole
pac-man model I don't they don't really
completely get it in there but it's
getting close and I imagine it get
better over time but if you can imagine
like putting the entire deep mind
control suite into one of these
generative models or even like the proc
gen benchmark it has this interesting
like now we're talking about
generalizing in these derivative models
let's say you take all 57 Atari games
that might not be enough but how long
until you can produce a new game like
learning these underlying rules with the
generative models and so we have
generative models and we can kind of
produce new data that dramatically
improves our ability
to get known unknowns like harvesting
the power of generative models is the
next step that's what I think is gonna
happen to go from local to broad it is a
good point right because so in in terms
of this Shola framework he talks about
these known unknowns let's say that's
data augmentation right if those are my
known unknowns like I know that my image
can be flipped and but you know in my
test set the flipped image should have
the same label and so on now with what
you're saying is pretty interesting
because if I not have ever built a
generative model of the data I I don't
know what it's going to produce per se
right and I'm going to build in some
from priors because of my architecture
but that would already cross over in my
mind into these unknown unknowns because
now I am letting that generative model
of the data produce training data and I
don't exactly know what's gonna come out
of that right and and then I'm going to
train my classifier on these data points
that I didn't know existed before oh I
think that's a yes a pretty good pretty
good point of course the counter
question is something like is there
there's like no new introduction of data
in this process right because you build
a generative model occur all over the
same data that you train your classifier
on and then all the additional
information information theoretically is
simply coming from the the architecture
of the generator so maybe that just
expresses a failure of us to properly
build a classifier on top of data you
recently made a video on the synthetic
petri dish paper and I've been really
into the generative teaching networks
thing where we use this objective to
produce the data in the generator like
and generative teaching networks the
goal is just learn a classifier on CFR
10 like as quickly as possible and then
it produces this data that you might
describe to human as an unknown unknown
you couldn't a human would never design
that data set it's like yeah complete
noise so maybe I can just optimize the
object like can use the generative model
in an way to search for these unknown
unknowns that by definition we can't
possibly be in the loop right like yes
it's a good point yeah is there's
generalization to data and tasks right
so yes in this case the known unknowns
is that just another way of saying
interpolating or is it another way of
saying any data which is on this
manifold so there's generalization to
something which is off the manifold then
there's also another type of
generalization which is doing a slightly
different task it might be instructive
just to look at this spectrum of
generalization that Francois talks about
in his paper so in his formalism Jannik
talks about system centric and developer
aware generalization so system Cedric is
generalizing let's say two images we've
not seen before
and he says that the generalization
power due to prior knowledge is
currently ignored on this metric so an
example of this would be I'm building an
image net classifier and it only
generalizes two things which the
developer had conceived of so for
example the test set on image net where
as this developer aware generalization
is about handling situations new to the
system and the developer
but is it talking about data or tasks
you can you can conceive any task as
data a good example with the Durham gain
paper I should earlier would be like a
system center or like a developer aware
thing would be knowing that the skin
color is gonna change or the location
and then maybe an unknown unknown would
be just like new kind of melanoma or a
new way of it by totally different way
yeah it goes up it goes up all the way
and that's what I've been like that was
my point at the beginning where he's
simply characterizing as the known
unknowns this is a tight generalization
as whatever we can do right now and so
he says something like oh yes of course
we're going to expect you know that the
thing to change a bit its location and
so on but so that's that's tight that's
narrow generalization broad
generalization would be something like
can this AI also solve other types of
skin disease problems right not only
because we train it on melanoma now can
it also solve other and then but as soon
as we come up with a deep learning data
augmentation method that does this he's
gonna redefine and say oh that's narrow
generalization can it also do other
medical types of tasks right and then
you know you know it just it just it
seems like the the borders there are
very much focused on what we can do
right now because 10 years ago he would
have said something like sure you can
train a classifier to classify melanoma
but can you also train one that then
generalizes to where the melanoma is in
a different place in the image no you
can't right I think one
that confuses me is just the predictive
architecture is very fixed and closed
domain you know we spoke about poet
which is this kind of open-ended
learning and it brings me to the wasn't
he a coffee cup challenge I know Yonex
got some interested comments to make
about that like having an IQ test before
you're allowed to go into the room but
but surely cites this as being an
example of broad generalization so what
if you could have an agent go into any
room and make a cup of coffee that must
be broad generalization and this agent
because I suppose what the reason I'm
thinking about this is before we were
talking about an image net classifier
generalizing to data off the manifold or
data you know from a different test cell
something but that architecture is
completely fixed whereas if you're
talking about an agent based
reinforcement learning algorithm that
could control a robot that's a fixed
architecture which could in theory be
able to generalize to making a cup of
coffee in a lot of different rooms
yes but imagine we just become first of
all we become extremely good at sim to
real right so that we don't need many
real-world training data and then second
of all we for some reason someone just
writes a really good simulator of all
the possible rooms with coffee machines
like you know there's this I here I
don't know if this is a myth but I hear
there's this elevator there's this
building manager game where the
elevators are so good there's this like
super old computer game so that elevator
engineers use that game to test their
elevator algorithms or use like mods of
that game so imagine someone just comes
up with an extremely good simulator of
that where literally you're all possible
thinkable situations happen at some
point and you could just train forever
with with your 50 billion TP use or
whatever we have at that point like NP
use but no you train and then you do the
same to really adapt very quickly but
what sure they would say like no that's
that's not intelligent you bought this
with a lot of data right so coming
coming in with this robot example
and saying like that's an example of
broad generalization I can taste chalets
own viewpoint and say no you have to
conditioned on how much experience it's
gotten it's only broad generalization
when it has gotten little experience in
coffee cup filling and can do this type
of stuff I think in order to learn your
simulator you're never gonna be able to
enumerate all the rooms at the coffee
cup so it becomes like how can we learn
our model or our simulator with as few
as examples as possible so I just think
it but little acquisition efficiency we
should be talking about the generative
model because like MIT like if you have
this perfect generative model that's
learned the natural image manifold and
then we have a data augmentation search
technique we can just enumerate what we
need you know get the unlimited
experience and then it becomes like
tic-tac-toe where there is no
generalization needed because we've seen
every possible room that makes sense but
then it's so we practically though how
do we learn these generative models
before we have 57 games right now we
want to introduce a new game that's the
question I think
surely would also take issue with your
generative model because if you had a
perfect generative model yeah the
question is how did you learn it and if
you learned it with very few samples in
just from today's standpoint that must
mean your priors that you built in are
so excellent right are so attuned to the
problem you're trying to solve he would
then also argue that something is not
intelligent if you've put a lot of prior
knowledge into it so his two things are
something is not intelligent even though
it performs well if it has had lots of
experience or and/or it has had it be
interesting to contrast the Wozniak
coffee cup robot versus alphago alphago
the environment is a board so it's a
discrete space and the algorithm Chalet
would argue you has no generality
whatsoever I might argue that it does in
the sense that the the networks that
model the board use a convolution on
your network and that has this
translational and equivariance so so it
will it will know that this pattern of
stuff over here is similar to this
pattern of stuff over here so there is
some generality but it is actually
really rigid though isn't it when it
would it be even harder to do something
like that if it was a robot making cups
of coffee because that space if you
imagine all of the possible worlds that
this robot could live in that that's
vast compared to this fixed board that
you play go on well to continue on this
like in play 7x7 go pretty well but 19
by 19 so I am terrible at it but it is
such a bit a bit more dramatic
transition compared to like a red or a
blue coffee mug or maybe would be like
encountering a whole new coffee machine
yeah but the transition I think is very
dramatic well I I can say something
that's sort of countering that in that
because you're now starting always from
the beginning where it's always the same
go board but if I simply cut off the
start of the game
it's an entirely different situation
time of course it's always on the go
board but it's entirely different right
and every single situation is inherently
complex like one stone that's a bit to
the left or to the right or missing
makes the gameboard entirely different
and it's it's just a matter of numbers I
feel because in this in this coffee cup
example here's the periodic table of
elements right and ultimately every
single kitchen starts with that and is
simply built upon the periodic table of
elements and in fact it's it's probably
some combination from Ikea and and so it
I feel it's just a matter of of scale
but the principle isn't that much
different I think
you could certainly argue that the older
AI systems like deep blue they required
explicit programming from humans down to
a great level of detail you could argue
that some of these new deep learning
systems they are implicitly programmed
because they are they are trained to a
certain extent on lots of data but you
could argue though that alphago is very
much like deep blue in the sense that it
has this this policy network but it's
still doing this Monte Carlo tree search
and it's kind of recursively looking
ahead as planning and it's looking at
all of these potential future situations
so that even though that would in sense
generalize to many other types of game
it still seems to me like there's a lot
of human knowledge encapsulated in that
algorithm but any coffee cup robot is
gonna have like a giant amount of human
knowledge abyssal ated in it
I just don't see why the coffee cup
example is so different from the alphago
example ultimately each like each go
situation is ultimately different except
it's on the same board and I can make
the same argument and say each kitchen
is ultimately different but it's made
from the same stuff starts from the same
point the makers of the house decide to
arrange it in a different way what about
like the adversarial nature of it like
the fact that you're not just like the
making the coffee thing things are
pretty deterministic if you pick up the
coffee it's you know likely to just move
upwards it's not gonna weigh differently
all of a sudden I think that adversarial
component of it actually does totally
change them do tasks I'm not sure you
simply have an environment and in go the
environment just always responds you can
just assume you need always responds
with the optimal action criticism of go
the chess is like once it goes out there
then they put they open source the model
and then people find these adversarial
ways of like these little things that
like I found this way to exploit the
models blackened knowledge and so that
that's why we're like oh it's not that
good compared to the coffee robot where
we don't really like test it with these
very bizarre little things but we could
do just the same like if I built this
coffee robot right now and it can go
into any kitchen and so on I'm pretty
sure if it's built on current technology
it's going to have like some CNN in it
and then I can build an adversarial
example for that CNN put it on the
fridge bang and the robot will just be
completely you know disturbed by it like
alphago is but the analogy would be if I
told if I told you without building
alphago what if I had a robot that could
play go and beat any human that's like
saying if what if I had a robot that
could go into any kitchen I don't see
the distinction there except the scale
except the numbers even if you go by
Shirley's definition of intelligence
it's simply a matter of how much prior
goes into it and how much experience
goes into it
so what do we think about these priors
like this idea of unlimited priors and
we have the CNN Pryor which is really
great this local kind of dependency and
images but so how do we find these
priors there's the idea of the core
knowledge right where he names like more
priors that humans have but that to me
that was like the idea of the
input-output way of testing for the
priors right like house do they find
these core knowledge priors I guess
someone sits down and thinks okay what
do all humans have and then I guess you
can do some kind of tests but this is it
seems like this is entirely speculative
right these priors that humans have
innately
who knows even harder
because basically says you should build
a system that has the same priors
built-in as humans and that's that is
like if that is so hard I have made the
argument when I looked at this art
challenge he says something like yeah
you should build in the priors of human
core knowledge into a system that if you
want to compare it with humans and to me
that task is as hard as solving AGI like
if I could perfectly programmatically
describe human all the priors that go
into humans ah it could build AGI well
so that would be my question though is
how do we then like binding the priors
seems to be like this manual process of
like try and fail and repeat and like
that's how we come across the CN n these
ideas like curriculum learning or data
augmentation like consistency
regularization mod could be interesting
to try to like so to me the best way of
doing this would be like a large-scale
evolution search and not use gradients
to try to find priors the question is
always what do you search over right for
example one prior that show Leia says
humans have innately is the object
deaths prior the assumption that the
world is made of objects that these
objects are somehow local have
boundaries and can interact with each
other by sort of contacting each other
how do you even construct a search that
would result in something like this so
to me that's far away and I think his
argument is more that if you want to
build an AI system you should explicitly
program in the notion that there are
objects but how to do this who knows and
if you go by his reasoning you should
program in this object nests prior
exactly or as close as possible to how
humans have it innately right it's not
like it's written down it's it's an
object is like much more we can't even
define it really in language words in
order to compare it you should program
it as closely as possible and my
argument is that if I could do this for
all of the human priors I would already
have AGI so I think it goes a little bit
back to well first we need we can't have
catastrophic forgetting we can't have
these neural networks that learn tasks
and then forget object permanence so I
think that would be the first thing to
solve and then we could have this like
multi objective optimization with
something like generative teaching
networks or synthetic petri dish if we
scaled up the computation where the
objective is like perform all these
tasks so it's kind of now transitioning
into his criticism of superglue and the
animal AI Olympics what do you think of
these benchmarks that are like a
combination of tasks
yeah I mean he probably it probably
makes the point that you still know the
tasks beforehand or you still know what
kind of tasks appear and that's what I
find so interesting about this art
challenge like I really I really
disagree that solving the art challenge
would give us anything intelligent like
I I'm gonna make this call already
before we have it usually people make
that call after you have a system like
this I'm already going to make that call
and but I I find it a super interesting
challenge by itself but he would argue
that you still know the tasks that are
coming at you and you should build a
system where you don't know the sort of
tasks that are coming at you now of
course in the arc challenge you know the
task in the sense of you know the input
output format but the the logic behind
the test you have to rapidly acquire and
I think that's like a subtle point he
makes but I think when he says you
should reprogram human priors he wants
to say because he defines these
different kinds of priors right so he
has the goal you have the reflexes that
you hit get hit you like flinch we burn
we don't care about this and then he
says you have this object nest
navigation and so on those you should
pre-program but then the last set of
priors are the meta-learning priors like
your learning strategy and that he
considers that's intelligence
so but I I don't see it this like I
don't see a distinction between that and
these other priors like if I if I throw
if I could
exactly formulate the meta learning
strategies that humans have innately
again I would solve AGI I looked a shame
leg in and hatta that Shane leg actually
had a great presentation on YouTube and
one of the examples is this kind of
intelligence test question so you're
given a sequence of numbers 1 3 5 7
question mark and you need to find what
the rule is and maybe the rule is 2 n
minus 1 because it's just all of the odd
numbers but it could also be 2 minus n
plus and then this series so n minus 1
times n minus 3 times n minus 3 now as
humans we have this kind of built-in
Occam's razor so we would we would favor
the simple solution we would assume that
the answer to this intelligence question
test is the simple answer right yeah leg
and Hutta they formalized their
definition of universal intelligence and
this looks very very similar to anyone
who studied reinforcement learning I
guess would have seen something similar
to this so it has the concept of an
environment in agent a success function
and then you're summing the complexity
the K is the call McGaw of complexity
over all of the possible environments
and that is the canonical and of measure
of intelligence which is being taught so
there's a screenshot here of Thor
grapple teaching this that you see
recently they just put it on on YouTube
if I understand this correctly this
measures whenever these measures over a
range of environments
whenever the agent succeeds in that
environment it gets a it gets a bonus
that is inversely proportional to how
complex the environment is
yeah this complexity thing is Occam's
razor
so it's favoring the simplest solutions
but this it's the environment that's in
the Kolmogorov complexity that's what
confuses me
right the decay is it's K of mu and mu
is the arrow is there's environment so
favoring these simpler environments no I
mean but right it's not it doesn't say
the complexity of the agent that solves
the environment it simply says the
complexity of the environment so you'd
get you'd get a higher num we get a
higher reward for solving a simpler
environment
but me that to me makes makes just
little sense if this were the complexity
of the agent like if you find a
particularly simple agent that solves
this environment then that's more
intelligent than I could sort of make
sense of it
I'd still disagree but I could make
sense of it but here it seems like the
agents complexity is nowhere to be found
it should so the measure of success this
is for one agent and is a function of
the success valued over all of the
environments but the value is weighted
by the complexity of each individual
environment okay well that's bizarre too
because binary string that encodes the
environment is where we compressing the
whole environment such that we can
measure the complexity of it right you
just assume that you have a function
that gives you the shortest possible
program that generates this environment
okay so this is for a single agent
you've sort of
have the expected success rate over all
the environments but weighted by how
complex the environments are yeah so in
in the case of alphago would there just
be one environment
well who know who knows if you consider
no no I think you can formulate each
possible board situation as a different
environment so the initial position
would be the simplest environment right
I think in connection with Occam's razor
it's like the simplest environment is
most likely the most common environment
maybe like if I'm a baseball hitter um
you know it's best for me to be able to
hit a fastball than to hit like a
curveball or a slow pitch right so yeah
so I I guess it's like the Occam's razor
is this energy efficiency ID well it's
not but I'm translating a comparing
animal and machine intelligence it's
like we have this constraint where we
need to be energy efficient so we would
we wouldn't bother with the our complex
task that has the higher Cole MacGrath
complexity unless our success is really
high at it or something it's like I'm
only gonna get really good at chess
which has high complexity if my value is
really high so imagine this value on the
scale of zero to one is distributed so
it's mostly around like zero two zero
one and then yeah right then I think
exactly this this implicitly sort of
assumes that the distribution of
environments around us right and it goes
over I don't know what the scope of
environment here is but I think that's
what you're less definition would be
disagreeing with here that scope of
environment needs to be the human
environments because even if you if an
environment is like very simple or very
complex it doesn't matter if it's not
relevant to us and I I have I tend to
agree with Shola on this particular part
like with all of these measures you can
always you can always sort of pick them
apart by considering okay over what is
this over and so on I mean it might be
worth just quickly looking at chalets
formalism of intelligent first of all he
introduces the generalization difficulty
this definition of intelligence here is
very much attuned to having a training
set and a testing set right that's it
the definition that is formalized in
Sholay's paper as always as a basis that
you have a training set
and then you need to generalize to a
testing set and your intelligence is
proportional to how well can you solve
the test set from the training set
conditioned on your priors and
experiences and I think this this leg
inhaler definition has something
completely different in mind
when they talk about intelligence so
social lays is much more geared towards
a machine learning context I feel weak
because he explicitly says ok you have
like a training a training set and you
need to generalize from the training set
instead of just considering oh how well
can I solve problems what you want to do
is you want to look at a scope of tasks
and he makes the first part of the
papers basically arguing why we should
consider intelligence always as a scoped
over a particular set of tasks and he's
arguing that those are the human tasks
but intelligence or a scope of tasks and
now you simply average across all of
these tasks in that scope so you say how
well in an agent solve all of the tasks
in that scope and each task is now in
this special form where you have a
training set and the test set now other
than in machine learning these can be
way harder so the training set can be
like we're gonna see in the art
challenge as something like I give you
three examples of logical puzzle and now
I'll give you a fourth one and you need
to tell me what the solution is
so you simply average over all the
possible tasks in this scope and your
spool in each task is going to be how
well can you solve the test set which is
basically a generalization difficulty if
you're given the training set but you
would always divide by this prior plus
experience now you say you're more
intelligent the better you can solve the
test set from the training set but
you're less intelligent if the human
programmer has already built in a salut
to this because that would not make you
intelligent that would make your program
more intelligent or if the human who has
provided you with lots and lots and lots
and lots of examples of this task
already
how would you formalize all of the tasks
in a scope what would an example of a
scope be well that's that's the entire
question that's the that's the
difference between what I feel surely
and these other definitions because the
scope can be every conceivable task in
the universe every possible task that
humans can come up with every possible
task that I Francoise Shola can come up
with in these two months that I work on
the orc challenge that's again it feels
like if I could formalize exactly
formalize all the possible tasks that
the human scope the human task scope if
I could formalize all of them would that
already solve AGI in this form like
there's a pretty good argument to be
made that if I could formalize the tasks
I would have already solved a GI or
formalizing the human scope is as hard
as solving a GI
but this seems so much better to me just
coming back to this formula so Chalet is
saying the intelligence of a system is a
function of the scope of tasks and the
function of a curriculum to learn those
tasks and then for every single item in
the curriculum multiply it by the
generalization difficulty divided by
priors and experience that to me seems
very logical because when we come back
to leg and hunters definition it's only
talking about maximizing the success of
an agent in as many environments as
possible think the first problem with
that is this idea of like measuring the
generalization difficulty easily right
like that's that would be so hard to try
to write predict the generalization
difficulty of a task I think that's one
of the nerves 2020 competitions is
trying to predict generalization of a
model and that's what we were saying up
here function of the complexity so this
said this this efficiency of being able
to acquire new tasks is something that
chalets interested in so you have the
optimal training solution there right so
it basically means if I had a master
Oracle that gives me the optimal
training set solution and this you
imagine like a neural network that
completely over fits on the training set
like the the shortest possible program
that can solve the training set and only
the training set to optimal precision if
I give you that how much more do you
need to know to solve the entire task
and by the entire task I mean every
possible test set so the entire task
could be something like differentiate
cats from dogs and whatever image I give
you and then I say here is a training
data set with these five cats in these
five dogs right and the generalization
difficulty is going to be if I give you
the perfect solution on the training set
that doesn't care about generalization
how much more do you need to know about
how much more work do you need to put in
to solve
the entire task so if it just happens to
be such that the top left pixel is
always blue for the cats and always red
for the dogs then the optimal trainset
solution helps you nothing there's no
information about the global solution of
the task but if I give you decently
sizeable data set right and it turns out
that it's easier to actually describe
what a dog is and what a cat is in terms
of visual features then it is to just
hard code the training data right it's
shorter the program is shorter - the
weights of the neural network are
shorter than remembering the training
that then that solution would actually
tell you already a little bit about the
entire task so the generalization
difficulty would be easier for that task
so
you have a notion of training data set
already there the more you can read from
your training data set about the test
solution the easier the generalization
is this image is quite instructive as
well this is something that surely talks
about law says that in a lower
intelligence system there is a lower
information conversion ratio so your
operational area is generalizing and in
a much more shallow sense compared to a
higher intelligence system which as you
can see has a much broader
generalization in the space of
situations from what it saw during
training time well so what about like
bars factor graph being like most data
efficient way of learning these causal
relationships between the variables and
then on the other hand is like a nerd of
model that's learned like the image
manifold and now can likes one can
quickly do the distribution alignment
with the new task one the sparse vector
graph is more data efficient
but the other one is like more powerful
I think and it's like machine until it I
think that's like the difference is like
the human intelligence needs to do the
sparse factor grafting whereas the
machine can do like this dense sampling
generative model this sparse factor
graph idea that we discussed in when we
discussed benzos talk--i died clear
that's sort of the idea that human
knowledge or so is arranged in this
sparse factor graph that's a massive
prior on the world right that's that's
not just a simple prior that's not like
l2 regularization that's like a very
very strong assumption on the world and
it if it turns out that we are able to
solve tasks because we have this strong
prior then chalet would say you have
that strong prior built in right if you
can solve a task because of that you're
not really intelligent because you have
that prior and on the other hand he
would also say the deep learning system
that you've just given loads and loads
of data he's not intelligent because it
had this experience he makes this axis
of you can by scale with lots of prior
or you can by skill with lots of
experience and neither is intelligent
and I guess here's where I here's where
I disagree I I think eat the
generalization capability of if you say
alphago isn't smart because it's had
lots of experience to Train on the
humans
till the humans built alphago to
generate its own experience
right so but the humans couldn't do that
by themselves it's not like the humans
because in Charlie's definition it is
developer aware generalization includes
the programmers and basically says you
know whenever you have gotten something
from your programmers it doesn't count
in that case for the for the machine but
in my mind it's like the symbiosis of
the two neither could do it by
themselves but together they can do
rapid generalization well I think Auto
ml0 is the most open-ended AI algorithm
out there where there's just searching
for the ways to construct the program so
maybe that kind of system where it's
just searching for like how to combine
variables that I think could be
something that's close to not being the
human machine together yeah
yes but then that is so infeasible right
like I don't know zero isn't gonna
anything gonna be Delta go anytime soon
but surely would argue that and you know
he has this concept of an intelligence
producing skilled programs so he would
say that the intelligence system was
humans and the skill program was the
algorithm that we created yeah well
especially you could break it down
because then humans created a skill
program but it was kind of like a meta
program isn't it because it's a skill
program which can tune itself based on
interacting with the simulates our
humans today more intelligent than
humans a hundred years ago in in many
ways we are it's exactly as we were
saying before the Canon of go knowledge
has been built up successively over
generations and the Canon of human
knowledge is also built up because much
of our knowledge is externalized it
exists in institutions it exists on the
Internet we've never had a better
collective memory system now than before
well memory isn't the same as
intelligence right
it surely it's a factor in intelligence
because if if you were born tomorrow as
opposed to in the 18th century you would
have the benefit of this pluggable
solid-state hard drive which is the
Internet and that's like an externalized
mind in a sense sure but in terms of
psychometrics humans haven't really
gotten more intelligent in the last
hundred years I mean there's a little
bit of this effect where every
generation has a few IQ points higher
but it's not substantial like humans 100
years ago we're pretty much as smart as
we are today in terms of psychometrics
and chale is modeling his tests and his
formulations according to this notion
the same notion that the psychometric
cysts have right but I would argue that
if you look at what shulay says namely
how rapidly can you generalize to new
tasks humans today are vastly more
intelligent than humans 100 years ago
because if you give us a new task we can
just generalize so much more quicker
because we have computers because we
have all the kinds of things
well here's another thing if learner of
2020 compared to Connor in 1520 I have
these contact lenses that let me see
this the IQ test and I can quickly
understand the task so that's like
another thing with these psychometric
tests is like computer vision system it
needs to like see the Rubik's Cube and
process the state of the Rubik's Cube
and there's that lag between seeing and
then representation that I think that we
that we're leaving out of this like
solving a Rubik's Cube and then solving
a Sudoku puzzle right it's the vision
the perceptual test what we're doing
with deep learning right is solving
perception like yes but I think that's a
huge part of this psychometric test is
you know I can see the IQ test faster
now I'm not better at solving it but I
can process a little more faster I'm not
sure if that would make a significant
difference but I'd like to pick up on
what Yannick said which is the you
asserted that humans now would have
better generalization capability than a
hundred years ago the whole point of
these IQ tests is to test fluid
intelligence not crystallized
intelligence it this is the direction
that chalet wanted to go in even further
by increasing the diversity of tasks
you're reducing any kind of carrier
because now if you go on an IQ test you
already understand roughly how to solve
it so why do you think that humans can
generalize better now
well I'm riffing on these different
definitions of intelligence like why do
we even model intelligence according to
these psychometric tests I mean yes were
somehow assessing a single human's brain
generalization to these things but I
would argue that humanity as a whole can
generalize so much quicker now then a
hundred years ago like an organism like
deep mind you can throw a problem at
that and it's going to be solved but
this is not captured by any of the
intelligence tests this isn't so you say
from Sholay to say like yeah something
like alphago isn't really intelligent
technically true in a dis psychometric
or generalization capability test that
he develops but I would say deep mind as
an organism and I don't mean the people
of deep mind
mean the computers but the symbiosis
leap mind as an organism is so much more
intelligent than anything a humanity had
a hundred years ago that's what I'm
saying yeah how would you measure that
well in this in the same way I think I
feel there are these different different
is she right he says okay alphago isn't
really intelligent but then we should
look at generalization capability which
this is a clear indication of
generalization capability I throw go at
deep mind they solve it in a year or two
years right the skill program that they
generated does not generalize their
intelligence generalizes no if I measure
each of the deep mind people I will find
they're not much smarter than they're
generally up for like high IQ people in
the 1800s it's the organism is the
symbiosis that's smarter that can
generalize orders of magnitude more
quickly than any of conglomerations of
human and machines could generalize in
the 1800's so that's that's one notion
of Schiller's but then he also says we
should model it after psychometrics but
by psychometric standards we haven't
gotten any smarter right and so I'm just
saying that all of these things are so
arguable and debatable and you can yeah
if you talk about generalization
difficulty as intelligence
you can always construct these counter
things that just make like at the end of
the day you'll say like oh you know I
still don't know anymore than I started
with
there's also the information efficiency
thing as well because what you're saying
is almost a step away from that because
when you look at deep mind as an
organism there's a lot of inefficiency
there there's a lot of trial and error
it's it's a process which looks quite
similar to evolution actually lots of
random things going on and the best
things survive that doesn't really help
us when we're talking about creating an
intelligent system on one computer it's
like interesting that you might have
this like this system that's like this
one fully connected network and then you
have like these autonomous agents that
it's like kind of this like the separate
program theory of mind like previously
we had this idea that it's like these
separate things do these different tasks
and then come together maybe we have
like the separate things but they're
still learning based systems like we
have our image classifier and then we
have like a learn data augmentation
procedure a learned consistency
regularization and like this kind of
system of like structure and then
autonomous learning agents within it
maybe my new favorite theory of mind
well who knows as you say is it's a
constellation of many different things
and then you might you might get this
emergent phenomena this this a RC
challenge it's fascinating to me because
I think Chalet what he wanted to
demonstrate was that artificial
intelligence doesn't really exist this
looks just like an intelligence test the
big one goes to the small one and that
big one goes to that small one and that
big one goes to that small one and what
does the next big one go to right
there's you always have the number of
demonstration examples and then you have
one test example where you do not know
the output grid okay so the answer to
this would be a grid the size of the
black masked region here yet and it
would be of course you can just use
symmetry so it would be something that
looked like this area there I would
imagine yeah I mean it's maybe for
people who haven't seen this yet so the
arc challenge consists of tasks just
like this where there's always an input
grid and an output grid and in each in
each task so this entire thing that you
see here can be thought of as one
training example and the label of the
training example is where the question
mark goes and in each of these training
examples you always have as you always
have multiple instances of
demonstrations where somebody would like
show you look this is how you would do
that particular task and then you have
one test instance where you don't know
the output grid but I mean this is super
difficult
so the algorithm has to first of all
decide how big the output grid should be
and the only training data if you will
you get from this task or these examples
right here it's not like there is a big
day it's not like you know in imagenet
paper you see like here is a bunch of
examples of our dates like this is the
task this is all of it you get these
three examples
and that's it and you have to decide
look at that the output grid isn't even
the same size in in all of these so this
is immensely complex and you somehow
have to figure out the rule from just
these few examples yeah so I I love this
this type I don't think it has much to
do with intelligence but I love this
task absolutely if we try to sell you on
this idea of like the contact lens thing
a little longer it's like don't you
think there's a huge entanglement with
your ability to perceive this and then
and then get the logic out of it like if
you go back to that first one you showed
me the like yeah pink yellow green tile
thing less it's more of like a
perception task it's like comparing
we're like the task of Where's Waldo do
playing a Sudoku like some of these
things it's like perceiving it is crazy
hard absolutely maybe that's the kind of
prior that we have when we look at this
we can just recognize the symmetry
immediately yes maybe that's a very
human thing what would that look like
for an algorithm would an algorithm be
trying to because I suppose if you take
a cell here you could swap the
coordinates and you could see if the
color was the same but what we what we
do now go ahead and do with it just try
all of these different priors looking
for symmetries there's lots of stuff in
here like the symmetry you only for
example you only recognize the symmetry
because it's in color right if if this
was an actual numpy cuz the machine is
not gonna see this as colors the machine
is going to see each color as a
different number and if I would just to
show you a grid of numbers I bet you'd
have a hard time recognizing the
symmetry in this like maybe we can try
but this design is going to be like hard
as hell for you as a human so I and this
is one of the criticisms here even
though
you know this this challenge is supposed
to be oh we you know we we explicitly
list all of the of the priors that are
in there the prior that humans perceive
color
so abstractly that's one of the things
that isn't listed I know that there is
that famous example in reinforcement
learning as well that we don't realize
all of the human priors we have when we
play a computer game versus an r-la
agent we understand what ladders mean
that you can go up and down on a ladder
an RL agent isn't going to know that but
coming back to this let's turn the thing
on its head a little bit right it's one
of the things that Shirley wanted to do
with this AARC challenge was increased
the diversity of tasks and also not
procedurally generate the tasks because
if you generated them with an algorithm
it be easier to reverse-engineer them
but what if it was framed as a machine
learning problem and we had let's say
hundreds of thousands of examples what
if it was just this symmetry task here
and we had hundreds and thousands of
examples machine learning would be able
to find a shortcut and easily figure out
wouldn't it well it arguably will be
able to learn the symmetry right he will
be able to learn what symmetry means in
this particular case right it wouldn't
be able to that structuralist point is
that a machine that's trained on
thousands of examples like this one
would sort of remember all the
symmetries it would learn what it means
to solve this particular task but it
wouldn't learn what symmetry as a
concept is and a human innately knows
what symmetry as a concept is and if you
are to solve this particular task from
from just these three examples that sort
of means that you also it's almost a
requirement that you understand what
symmetry is right and this is the next
that sort of a criticism I have here is
that a lot of these tasks I feel they
test they sort of
test more whether a system has these
priors than anything else because right
he says well a system should have these
priors already built-in and now we're
going to test its generalization
capability but a lot of these tasks
actually just they they sort of it's
more of a test of do you have these
priors built-in and then the second
thing is these things aren't
procedurally generated which is pretty
cool because that means you know there's
more diversity there is they're probably
smarter examples like whenever when I
saw each of these in the paper I'm like
oh wow of course that's also possible
and like whoa like beings you can never
get that with procedural generation but
I feel it is going to be almost
impossible to just reduce yourself to
these priors that you explicitly list
because it's it's like I think there are
so many unspoken assumptions still in
these tasks
he says you shouldn't do that you
shouldn't make a task where there are
implicit assumptions but I feel if he if
he then goes ahead and and by handcrafts
these things even if he really tries to
not put any more assumptions in there
there are so many assumptions in there
if you look at these tasks that are not
listed I wonder how many priors there
are because it seems that if you're
dealing with a two-dimensional grid
surely you could enumerate
all of the possible priors in terms of
symmetry and continuity and so on but
this is quite interesting so a person on
reddit came back to us and said that
it's an interesting idea but why not
just use a different type of problem so
apparently there's Hopf starters string
and allergy problem so AAA is the BBB as
CCC is - question mark so the answer
there is probably DDD and then there's
some more sophisticated versions of that
it seems to me that it's almost exactly
the same type of system - reasoning
required
yeah I mean for the first one and
Shirley would say no that's not valid
because you would need to know the ABEC
and that sort of world knowledge and all
you'd have to program this into into the
AI and yeah the second one I agree
that's sort of the same but that would
not conform to the definition of these
are like human scope tasks maybe though
a human can solve it so yeah I give that
that's that's a pretty good pretty good
analogy honestly it's just more fluffy
to do it in a pail they all said that
that's where these obvious priors these
human priors come in because right here
what you're seeing when you look at this
is like you know the green thing going
to the red thing
I mean it's so weird you immediately
perceive the green thing like extending
and going to the red thing crazy right
so I I don't think how you could map
this efficiently into this string based
representation except you know maybe you
have like zero zero zero zero zero zero
and then like a three and over here a
five and then 0 0 0 0 and then the 3
like goes to the 5 or something like
this you know but then it would be you
would be back to these grids again
because essentially that's that's a grid
so I feel these string tasks they also
express the same logic but they do not
contain these fundamental priors but
then the question is is it necessary
that you have them in there for
measuring intelligence who knows is it
over competition
yes I do think so are the two hundred
secret test examples are they now public
I don't know because I I don't want them
to be public I want them to be forever
hidden because that I don't know but
that's just going to be like fun for the
future because I haven't had my try at
this yet I find it pretty interesting
because he himself shall a goes and says
how would you solve something like this
right in the paper he has a section
about how would one what a solution
might look like and if you go to step
one of that it's like build a
domain-specific language to capture all
of the possible tasks and I'd like so
it's like create a programming language
that creates programs whose outputs are
these tasks and then step two is like is
it use the pro sign language to to to
match like find the program in that
programming language that outputs the
examples that you see of the task and to
me is like how do you solve AGI step one
build AGI because if I had a DSL that
sufficiently outputs these tasks and
narrowly enough so that it doesn't
output anything like not a Turing
machine then I would have already solved
AGI in or at least I would have solved
the arc challenge so how do you build or
challenge of arc arc challenge isn't
that the same as him advocating to build
an expert system which is precisely what
he said we shouldn't do the beginning me
maybe yes
yeah it's like yeah build a DSL and then
match the DSL third of you I guess
yeah it's tough especially it comes back
to Minsky's 1968 definition of AI which
is that it's the the science of making
machines capable of performing tasks
that would require intelligence if done
by humans and I think that's a
completely meaningless statement by the
way that's the problem with intelligence
is you just can't get a handle exactly
that's right that's what I've been
saying at the end of the day here in
Minsky's definition of intelligence
it contains intelligence right so how
much more how much more washy can you be
and this at the end of the day you're
you you'll always be like I don't know I
know when I see it or something like
this it's it's like end
again but but we've based evaluation
that's what I said at the beginning
we're now at this art challenge and
again it's a skill based evaluation I
think this is it I think we're coming
full circle because we are now coming
back to
Minsky's view of artificial intelligence
so Minsky said the problem of
intelligence would be solved if only we
could encode human skills into formal
rules and encode human knowledge into
explicit databases and that's exactly
what we've just been talking about on
this arc challenge we're talking about
coming up with rules and knowledge to
describe all of the things that you can
do and all of the different types of
symmetries and so on is that not exactly
what Minsky said in 1960 whenever it was
a long time ago sounds awfully close
right but I've had this I've had this
idea about how to solve this so hear me
out on this one you know we've talked
about GPT 3 and GPT 3 looks an awful lot
like that like gee Petey's 3 in context
learning looks an awful lot like this
thing right here like you have three
examples of a task and give me like the
fourth one you need to solve that looks
like what jeep exactly what GPT 3 does
right so it has never trained to
translate but it can translate due to
this in context learning now it can do
so because it has seen lots and lots and
lots of variants of these things during
training but probably never exactly that
so my approach would be to build a giant
training dataset and then train
something like GPT 3 on this to do
exactly this kind of in context learning
now how would I go about building this
training dataset I would do sort of what
shoe laces with with his DSL what I
would do is I would look through all
these priors and for each one I would
write a function so for example one of
the functions could be produce asymmetry
that function would take like a generic
great object put it in and then it would
output a symmetrized version of that
object or like extend line would be a
function and that would take in
something it would just try to extend
that so if this is a like a big thing
and so I would sort of it's it's like
reverse engineering the makers of the
arc challenge but instead of what Chalet
says build a DSL that describes the
problem I would simply try to come up
with a training data set that mixes and
matches and then I will just randomly
apply these functions one after another
so one gives me first the symmetry and
then a line and then a time and then a
something going towards something and
the other one gives me you know a bunch
of other things and do you do some date
augmentations where I swap all the
colors and so on
and and that and that training data set
I would then train GP t3 on to do the in
context learning that's how I would go
so this in GP t3 is like brute-forcing
this problem of multimodal
outputs it's like a zoo and saw a
would-be gorilla tiger cat I don't know
like just brute forcing this multimodal
output problem but I think images is
going to be too high dimensional for you
to do that
you're going to need like so all word
tokens are like one-dimensional maybe
like a thousand lengths right so you're
going to need to put all your images in
that kind of dimensionality to brute
force multimodal outputs
I'm not sure I mean I do maybe I don't
I don't know you could also just
generate one pixel after another or
something like this and then it's just
the sepia mask
I was always thinking about them but
could could I just articulate back to
you I'm interested to reason about how
many possible priors could there be is
it ten thousand is it a hundred that
let's imagine that you came up with a
hundred and it was all of the usual
suspects like you know contiguous lines
and homogeneous shapes and you know all
of that kind of stuff and then you
procedurally generated many many
instances of boards that had
representations of these rules that you
generated so now what you've basically
done is you've created an encoder that
can represent any board configuration
yes and then you can use that
representation and generate lots of
maskings and you can train it to fill in
the mask is that kind of what you're
saying no no I would wear the mask the
masking itself would be one of these
functions that I that I trained on so if
you ask how many priors are there and
then if we ask okay how many priors are
there for human intelligence probably
uncountably many or at least in a way
you could describe programmatically
you'd need uncountably many programs
however you don't have to match the
human priors you have to match you have
to think of what kind of priors did
false wash Olay think of when he
constructed the ark challenge and that's
a much smaller set that's probably going
to be in the order of a hundred and you
might go overboard a bit because you you
you probably can come up with more you
rather over sample right so and and
that's why I think when someone solves
this when I like let's let's say I solve
this and then I say look this is how I
did it I just constructed the big
training data set out of these 100
custom functions I wrote and I compose
them in random order each time and then
I train GPT 3 on it
I you know statistical inference in
context learning output whoo but that
would be impressive but the AI effect
would kick in and say wait that's not
intelligence you simply coded these 100
functions well so the the cackle
challenge now presumably it's all about
diversity of tasks so almost every
single every single example you get is a
novel task or a composition of these
priors so when when you get evaluators
you'll be evaluated against lots of
things that you've not seen before but
you're saying that it's somewhat
predictable because it was all conceived
by a few human beings yes exactly and
you only have to match that thought
process or your your thought process has
to the thought process of these people
has to be like in the convex hull of
what you can come up with and if you
have the Titan of convex hull you can
replicate that because you said the the
number of priors as conceived by France
Marshall a is very small and I think
that there will be a compositional
relationship between them so if you take
all of the grids that are on the test
set on Cagle and you write a
domain-specific language to generate
many many permutations of these there
must be at least some transfer to the
grids that you've not seen yeah I mean
the interesting thing here is the fact
that humans can solve all of them right
and they've tested this and the result
is as reasonably smart human can solve
all of these tasks without problems
without instruction right and of course
any system you built is going to have
some parrying over because you've
thought of some of the things right but
that the the interesting thing is humans
can solve all of them and that means one
of two things either one who haven't
sufficiently been able to encapsulate
these core knowledge priors and the meta
learning procedure that leads to this or
to that in these tasks there are
actually more assumptions than are
stated in the challenge implicitly I
don't know but I'm gonna count on a
significant number being of this second
third it's really interesting because
even now when we're talking about
solving this we are doing exactly what
chalet said we would do which is to find
a shortcut but yes if we did know if we
did know about all of the priors then it
doesn't seem like it's even artificial
intelligence anymore it's something that
you could just write using code that's
that's my entire point if either because
Charlie says you should explicitly list
all of the priors that go into your
intelligence test and my point is if you
could explicitly list all the priors
with the sufficient detail such that you
can make them formal you would have
already solved the problem it's as hard
as solving the problem exactly I mean
that's my that's my he might disagree
say well I only mean whatever is not the
meta learning prior but then
yeah okay bill even even that I could
write down like if I could I could
formally write down because that's just
a human prior as well in these priors
are like these discrete things right
like adding on data augmentation or
something it's lighter you search for a
prior this is the meta learning thing
what we're talking about now is
explicitly formalizing the priors a bit
like 20 years ago when we used to
formalize knowledge in grass but you're
saying I want to look at this prima
facie so that for the first time and I
want to discover what these priors are I
think Chalet is moving towards this
program synthesis thing so what Chalet
wants to be able to do is go from this
grid to this grid but generate some code
to do it you know it imagine the code is
like into a Python function right so
it's a combination of A to Z at each of
these slots and we could do like an
evolution search until we find this
algorithm that does a RC right but it
would be going to take like all the
computation in the world but would that
be intelligent Oh what maybe it wait I
mean what if you could what if you could
generate many permutations of code and
it would just be basic looping semantics
that that mutated things in the grid and
and maybe you could model it as an agent
moving around the grid mutating cells
that it was walking over or something
and you managed to through this search
space of possible bits of code you
managed to find a bit of code that would
successfully mutate this cell into that
cell well there's going to be I mean
that's the exact difference to what to
what you had on this deepmind slide
right because there are going to be an
infinite number of programs that
transform that conform to all of these
examples like infinitely many I can
always make a more complex program that
also outputs these things right and even
if you think like the simplest programs
even the simplest programs they're going
to be many of them that conform to that
solution I think this is what Chalet is
trying to do is
he's trying to say I am only going to
consider solutions that humans and solve
and that's an entirely different thing
right because now of course when this
green thing goes to the red thing a
human can solve that because you know
for whatever reason we're like oh yeah
going to something over and these are
the obstacles of course but if I tell
you no actually that's not it the rule
is actually the agent you see AG always
goes one diagonal and then one left and
then if there's some of the blue ones is
50 it turns this one green and it just
so happens to in this grid to make sense
I think the focus of Chalet is whatever
a human can do whereas I think this what
you had on the deep mind slide is much
more agnostic
well that's right but could we make a
simpler version of humans humans have an
unknown number of priors why don't we
create a new measure of intelligence
within a set of priors that are well
defined
what why don't we create an IRC
challenge which specifically only has
let's say two priors and let's solve
that algorithmically which should
presumably be easy would that be a good
place to stop to get from that to AGI I
don't get how you would disentangle
these priors though
well what if we said that let's make a
new AARC challenge but this time it's
only going to have contiguous straight
lines so that means we can now write a
solution to do that using an expert
system right we can we can say given
this grid and I'm just going to continue
all of the lines in all the possible
directions maintaining the same color
and I'm going to select the the one
which produces one from the other and
also I'll take the simplest solution
that the simplest algorithm so I've kind
of solved intelligence in that truncated
space because you can write explicitly
down what you're doing or how you're
generating the environments you have
already solved the task and that that's
my point
what what chalet when he makes these
examples he what he wants to do is he
wants to say okay I'm gonna make
something that is only described by
object nests and goal-oriented nests but
then he doesn't formalize how he gets to
the solution he simply thinks he sits
there and he thinks okay I need
something that's like object and goal
oriented ah I you know I can think of
something here is I can think of
something right but in that process of
generating it without your formally
writing down just derived from the
assumptions
there are so many more assumptions in
that and I think a significant number of
these Ark tasks have these unspoken have
these more unspoken implicit assumptions
about human knowledge that neither the
maker of the problem realizes that they
put in and nor the test taker realizes
that they use because it's just so
obvious to humans that this is just my
opinion right but I feel there are so
many of these probably in this stuff
that this notion of make a DSL specific
to these priors is probably not going to
work and that means that probably my
approach is also not going to work my
approach would would actually not be
over these priors my approach would just
be to sit here and think like if I were
surely what would I do and that's
probably going to be a solution that
solves this thing ultimately let's let's
quickly come back to this hash table
thing do you think it's hyperbolic to
say that deep learning is like a hash
table
what can we let's look at this paper
write papers about networks essentially
being nearest neighbor searches I damage
it's all the question of formalism so in
this paper neural arithmetic logic units
it made quite a surprising observation I
know we've spoken about this before but
it says that deep neural networks
essentially can extrapolate not even on
the scale our identity function so the f
of X equals x so they trained it I think
between a range of -5 and 5 and when
they tested it outside of the training
range of course it was different
depending on the activation function it
couldn't extrapolate at all so given
that even in this case it can't
extrapolate on the scalar identity
function is it so hyperbolic to say what
Chalet says which is that deep learning
algorithms are conceptually similar to a
locally sensitive hashing function which
means they can interpolate between data
points they've seen given a
sufficiently dense sampling in the input
space I don't think it's that hyperbolic
no absolutely not the question yeah
any-anything is a hash cup if you have
the correct features and I accept in
these easy examples where we can
actually write down the function it's
debatable whether or not humans would
succeed so much better than deep neural
networks with deep neural networks I
feel like it's almost like as if it's
given the minus 20 to 20 range already
like it's already got this massive thing
that it doesn't even I don't like I
don't think it makes sense to try to see
if it what happens outside of the bounds
of it well that that's a really
interesting point because it's like what
we were saying with language that we've
got the convex hull of all of the
different words and someone on reddit as
well no sorry on our discord said can
you try and imagine a new color and of
course you can't because we could only
interpolate between right breathe and
blue but can you imagine a new word no
we can't we can only interpolate between
the convex hull so so what you're saying
Connor is that you know even if I have a
training set of all of these different
images of dogs for example can't you
can't really an extrapolation would be
well what's something that's not a dog
well of course it's not going to help
you with that or what's something that's
even more a dog than a dog
you can't generalize to new kinds of
animals you can say yeah okay but that's
an entirely like different new direction
in in the manifold space right but in
this case we're talking about can you
extrapolate from what you know and that
would be something like I'm gonna give
you the dog is dog you've ever seen can
you like it's it's so doggie it's like
not even not even close to these dogs
and you classify that and that's just
that's just not how data is in the real
world but how can we contrast this
conversation to what we were saying
about
AARC because it's not just the
extrapolation it's the information
efficiency right well in this in this AR
see I I think it's about rule finding
right ultimately this challenge is if
you if you see these three training
examples or actually if you see that
number thing on the deep mind slide it's
you do yourself think what's the rule
that's what you think there is an
implicit assumption there that there is
a rule right that's that's the implicit
summary there is a rule I need to find
the rule and the rule is going to be
somewhat simple in terms of the things
that I know and here is where the priors
come in right of terms of objects and
movement and so on but ultimately say
what's the rule and I don't know if that
has buddy with extrapolation but that
there is a difference though when shall
a was talking about the levels of
generalization one of the things he said
was tic-tac-toe for example it's not
really any generalization because you
can analytically enumerate all of the
possible states similarly on this AARC
challenge you can analytically enumerate
a lot of rules and a lot of things that
you can do on a more sophisticated
problem in the real world you know if I
come up with a rule of how I choose to
go on the bus or how I choose to pick up
something that's huge so any any rule
that I learn would need to be much more
of a meta rule it would need to
generalize to more situations yeah look
what if you have like a good
representation of the tiles and then you
have like angle of the vector that
transitions from like the labeled
examples you have three labels right so
there's like angle of the vector that
transitions each of them and the
meta-learning rule maybe is like to use
those angles in your representation
space to infer this new transition right
yeah me it's a multi-modal output
problem but I mean the representation I
had no idea how you have enough data to
train something like this right that's
the problem
but when reading some papers I'm like
transfer learning with Ganz where we're
trying to like train on image net and
now use it for melanoma classification
it's like what if you trained it on like
a massive amount of these kind of like
puzzles that could be similar ish do you
think that would be informative at all
yep might be too abstract so this cuts
exactly what I would I've proposed right
come up with a puzzle generator that
forever that you think closely matches
what what these people came up with when
they created the tasks and then train
something on it yeah that's
we're in but you would be cheating good
because you're what we need I think the
elephant in the room here is in order to
develop this kind of system to of
intelligence we need to have some kind
of symbolic programming right I don't
I've said at minute one of this
conversation that I don't think solving
the ark challenge is going to result in
intelligence I and
exactly because of that because the
solution to it is just going to be
reverse thinking of what the developers
intended and in my mind that's the only
solution because the number of implicit
priors are still too many that's that's
just by my opinion on that of that
particular thing I think there are a lot
of of reddit comments that are pretty
interesting to this No yes let's let's
start at the top so we went out to read
it and I kind of summarized chalets
paper into about 20 bullet points so the
first thing we got was this so the a RC
challenge this is from sure of Zorah in
all honesty that a RC challenge is a
good throwback to traditional machine
learning everything is getting cooked
with deep learning soup without much
transferable know-how heck you can't
even used language models in vision
settings going back to some of his
arguments he echoes some others who
rightly points how brain network are
amorphous and denser without the need
for BP I'll back the paper and the
challenge attempted to nudge the
community to think outside of the box or
what's meant by traditional ml is it
like linear regression I mean yes you
need you know you can have not a linear
regression to images and text it's just
not gonna work well you've got that
problem called the curse of
dimensionality yeah okay yes that's a
good point it's kind of bringing the
community back saying that instead of
building more and more specialized
solutions you
you maybe try to think of intelligence
as a broader being like try to think of
things that
generally apply to data but deep
learning itself is a pretty general
paradigm like of course we have CNN's
for vision and transformers for text but
in general it's like let's mix linear
algebra and nonlinearities and a bit of
normalization and backprop right
gradient descent I mean I just the fact
that I for example now call out this
flatland challenge where it's about
optimizing the Swiss railway network or
so it's a simulator of the Swiss railway
network and in the in the olden days
right I would have actually had to
understand something about the railway
network to do this but now my explicit
goal is to understand as little as
possible about trains and it actually
has a chance to work right by the way
anyone who is willing to participate in
this we're doing this completely in the
open yeah everyone's free to join in our
efforts but I I now have a good chance
of not having who have to learn
something about trains or schedule a
vehicle scheduling or whatnot because of
deep learning right similarly I can
build like a go in the chest and the
shogi bought they have no clue of chess
except for the rules right because of
deep learning
I can build like the best medical
systems are built by people that have no
clue of medicine they don't know how
long cancer looks they just know that
some doctor said this is lung cancer and
they they build so I feel deep learning
itself as a methodology is super general
it didn't mean that was the amazing
thing about deep learning that in the
olden days of classical machine learning
the data scientists were domain experts
and would write very sophisticated
feature extractors which did what you
needed them to do and now the incredible
thing is we have this ubiquitous toolkit
that we can just apply anywhere but it
only seems to work in certain situations
because that this person is saying that
it's a throwback to traditional ml I
think it's a throwback to expert systems
you can't use traditional ml one the IRC
challenge
well yeah you I mean you also you can't
use expert systems except if you cheat
and sort of think of what shall they
would have thought when he made the
Challenger anyway a presser of virgins
and by the way in generating just ripped
just before we get through a presser on
virgins
Yanik has set up a discord server where
he is running this flatland challenge
and we're all on that discord server so
feel free to join us and you can you can
talk to us at any time but yeah and
coming back to a pressure of virgins
said don't forget to take a look at his
Kangol challenge unlike his fresh way of
looking at things that a RC challenge
almost forces you to pinpoint the core
of human intelligence indeed
someone called panties in my ass says
what's the purpose of this YouTube
channel does it have any particular goal
that the world is awash with low quality
ml content and I feel this sub could use
some assurance that this channel is
actually worth paying attention to
no intention to disrespect just curious
it's a fair question that we are mostly
providing low quality ml content and
have no particular goal we don't even
follow a consistent format and the
videos are too long so yet there's no
purpose to this videos are too long we
haven't done a Siraj yet we haven't set
up a what did he do he set up some kind
of what was it school of AI yeah and
started selling courses we haven't done
that yet it's in the making it's just a
matter of time before we reach then
we're gonna replenish your money right
now so we don't even have to go through
the trouble he seems to give a pretty
definitive stance on the nature versus
nurture debate an empiricist versus
nativist debate that the key to building
general intelligence is to hard-code
fundamental human priors while I
personally largely agree with this I
think there's a lot to debate with
regard to how you decide what to
hard-code versus what to learn I wasn't
able to find much discussion on this
particular topic in the paper on my
first skin but I think this question is
pretty central to the topics of this
paper and should be a significant point
of discussion yes that's the the entire
point like you hard-code something's and
the learning in especially in the arc
challenge the learning is almost
non-existent right it's this rapid
learning from these very few
demonstrations there is no notion
I almost feel like it's all encapsulated
in one
like whether or not object Ness is a
learned property or a evolutionary
built-in property makes no difference to
the ark challenge and in in fact in the
measure of intelligence the formula its
prior plus experience nowhere in the
formula is the prior by itself or the
experience by itself so for the measure
of intelligence surely doesn't
differentiate between whether you've
acquired something through built in
through nature or through nurture and so
I I think for him it makes almost no
difference at all even though I agree he
does take like a pretty definite stance
and saying basically these things are
built-in but he wouldn't make a
difference if they weren't but if you
just simply learn them as a child
because in terms of the definition and
in terms of the ark challenge you want
to provide a system with these abilities
beforehand the what is quite interesting
though is that the skill programs that
these type of tests are looking for are
innate or acquired within the first 18
months of our development many of the
skill programs that we put into use
every single day are learned but we've
learned them throughout our lifetime yes
yeah but in something like the AR C
challenge the goal is not to learn
anything well the goal is to yet goal is
to generalize rapidly from these few
examples yeah I would say the the goal
is to apply some previous skill program
that we've already learned yes so he
also says a very related story to the
above is that of meta learning the idea
of meta learning as I think of it is
that you learn an inductive bias that
facilitates quick learning or good
performance on a family of tasks rather
than one task this may be debatable but
one can say that this can allow the jump
from local generalization to broad
generalization and then you get to the
question of what is the best way to
learn this in
of bias that accelerates your ability to
learn these tasks there's a kind of meta
meta learning program associated with
that and things don't really stop there
because you can have infinite levels of
abstraction I think a possible and very
subtle implication is that the jump from
broad generalization to extreme
generalization implies collapsing across
these levels of abstraction which is
something humans are able to do shoot
Schumann der Schumann der discusses this
collapsing concept in his 1987 thesis
yeah is this is that mr. Ellis Tian's
well technically Vytas is hello yes mr.
Ellis TM but yes yeah the schmidhuber
was his supervisor
I completely also agree with with this
point if you like if you think about
meta learning or multitask learning it's
it's kind of washy how its treated
nowadays in in deep learning but the
concept of it is sort of what we're
looking for like what's what's a good
algorithm that allows you to quickly
learn from new data the way it's framed
right now is more of I give you I give
you many different tasks in still in
machine learning language where I have
thousands of training examples where as
well I guess what's relay and he
specifically yeah I'm really biased by
this arc challenge but what he's looking
for is more like I give you three
examples right and and that's I feel
that's a different thing that the
current meta learning community is
addressing though I agree with the
commenter entirely here that meta
learning is essentially looking for
something like this and then I also
agree that there's these levels infinite
levels of abstraction and that somehow
in this level level level level there is
a a recurrence somewhere in
that recurrence might be called
intelligence you remember when we talked
about consciousness and benzo said
something like consciousness has to do
with attention and I feel it's the same
way there that no no humans can attend
to their attention and then act they can
attend to that and so on so it's sort of
this recurrence relation among these
these abstraction levels that makes the
intelligence or the consciousness and I
feel we're nowhere in machine learning
to capture that conductive prior that
like fits the structure of meta learning
like the original mammal paper this
inductive prior is that the initial
parameters are like the thing we should
share across the task but then it could
be like I think the latest ID like
metric learning is like we apply this
data augmentation view to it and that's
how we apply to contrastive loss and
like learn these object classes like
this is a cat by cropping it and then
comparing the two and then I think
another prior maybe is this idea of
generative models that we've been trying
to get after and I think the it's
interesting they like the structure of
how how are we going to share
information across tasks
interesting yeah yeah absolutely and I
think we quoted Christof Koch I think on
our consciousness Benji o1d you showed
me the article Connor and he said
exactly what Yannick just said which is
that you know real consciousness should
surely have this kind of recursive
reflexive self causal property it
shouldn't just be you noticed an
end-to-end neural network
he also says that he or she I don't know
if it's discussion of intelligence is
pretty human centric which seems
intentional however I think many animals
that we consider dumb a smart in their
own way for example we think rodents are
pretty dumb but they're very smart at
tasks that are ecologically valid to
them they are navigational geniuses for
instance and I think this is also an
important part of the discussion if I'm
coming back to the contact lens thing
one more time it's like like if you've
seen I guess have you seen the movie
predator how he sees in infrared oh yeah
he's like the hunter and he's seasoned
and infrared light so it's like really
easy to see them that's like if you can
see an infrared light you can if he good
at hunting but you're not going to be
able to do the AARC task regardless of
how well you can logically combine the
things oh yeah but the AARC challenge is
very anthropocentric because if you
think about it the intelligence that we
have is is very much a function of the
environment and how it can be expressed
through acting in that environment so to
an alien that AARC challenge would just
be a complete nonsense there's so many
ways to perceive the environment I think
we have like you know the RGB filter on
yeah or whatever the lights yeah yeah
exactly what what what sure they says
with with intelligence is in his mind
with respect to a given scope and in if
we built if we think about building a GI
and then we must give it a scope and the
scope that makes sense is the human
scope but but this is why I made the
comment earlier that surely we should
start by reducing the scope as much as
possible
and trying to solve intelligence in the
most truncated scope and then build
upwards from there to try and find the
scope of human tasks the formal
describing of the scope is that already
the same complexity as solving
intelligence even that scope but because
at some point from really simple to
human there's going to be a point where
you can't describe it any more formally
because you can describe the simple you
cannot describe the human scope and I
think at that point that's that the
critical barrier there and just to
unpack that a bit more it's not just
about describing what if what if you
could analytically enumerate all of the
priors that humans have what kind of
compositional relationship with those
prize have with each other and could you
describe that
okay so zombie cop zombie cop blip says
I should start with the caveat that I
just skimmed the 64 page article so my
assessment is likely way off so the
macaw duck AI effect is probably the
most relevant point here and this this
is that every time we do something
intelligent people say oh that's not
intelligent AI research in the past has
done a lot in the way of logical
reasoning but it turned out that it was
easy to get a computer to be more
logical than a human so a good example
for this is rule induction and inductive
logic programming so the recent research
can be thought of as emulating what we'd
call intuition in humans which is
actually hard for computers to do as
with humans intuition doesn't generalize
very easily although the ramps paper
seems to ignore transfer learning and
meta learning so he seems to be unhappy
about that he or she it is true that few
researchers try to achieve general
artificial intelligence though the
author downplays some achievements well
alphago was specific to go alpha zero
and mu zero are absolutely intelligent
systems that work on more systems than a
human could master core knowledge is
normally known as an ontology
and is an old concept with Google
knowledge graph probably being the
largest one with these nets out of the
way
the authors assumed that intelligence is
a 1d scale of a system which makes the
system sound very dependent on the tasks
presented to it
the authors assumed that generalization
is somehow more valuable than skill the
market tells us otherwise generalization
has a pretty low return on investment
the authors admit that human perception
of intelligence is very limited but
still abide by it I think this is a red
herring which would enforce more
human-like AI by sacrificing the
advantages that AI already has over us
with regard to logical thinking and the
ability to ignore human priors and yes
he says I'm aware that most ml does not
do this at all by using human provider
datasets and he finishes with however I
do like the general point the paper is
making I would like to see more
development in AGI as for me it's
probably the coolest thing ever I did
love the discussion of gödel Asia and
bark which is a book that was written I
think in the late 1970s I'm a bit
disappointed that they explicitly want a
human centric approach and I think they
don't seem to appreciate the work on AGI
very much even though they're proposing
it I mean this okay to the second point
specifically the authors assume the
generalization is somewhere more
valuable than skill the market tells us
otherwise how expensive is the source
code of alphago and then ask yourself
how expensive is the team that built
alphago
so I I disagree that skilless is valued
by the market it's maybe particular
specific skill but I think the return on
investment on generalization is he's
very high and also I mean to teach the
commenter here is absolutely correct
surely does focus on generalization but
that's just that's that all is choice
right he simply says I define
intelligence as the generalization
difficulty over a scope of tasks which
is to the first point when Det author
ear is correct but that's that's the
choice surely makes and he argues it
well and what I find most interesting is
that's like well very first sentence
that you said Conner mu0
are absolutely intelligent system that
work on more systems than a human could
master what's your what's your you have
like a more elaborate take on that
well I think we're we're still on this
idea that like well model-based
reinforcement learning you learn a model
and then you learn it in a latent space
so that it's tracked computationally
tractable I mean at least for robotics
is when I opened up with just thinking
that like mu zero could work for
robotics and I you know it seemed like
dreamer is a good example of this like
the planet paper the same idea of like
let's learn a latent space world model
and then planning it could could you
articulate what's different about musi
Rho and alpha zero compared to alphago
well I think what is so different is
that the in the latent model when you do
like a transition if you know the chess
like that if you have the chess board
you know what then if you move your
castle you know what happens next
whereas with new 0 they're gonna use the
compressed latent space and not use like
the simulator the ground truth
transition so like state action next
state transitions if you use that ground
truth lookup that makes the problem like
it so much easier compared to learning
those transitions okay and and with
alpha 0 I think I think the point is it
wasn't given it doesn't know the rules
of the game it wasn't given examples of
actual games played by humans it just
starts from nothing it learns the rules
of the game from the simulator so it it
could potentially you could feed in
chess for example a chess simulator and
it would learn it exactly the same it
doesn't care that it's go as long as
it's an adversarial 2-dimensional board
game using that ground truth chess board
to do the Monte Carlo tree search so
that's what alpha 0 is like not general
because of that I guess yeah exactly
there is an interaction between the
simulator and the learn about part
because at every point in the Monte
Carlo tree search in alpha in alpha go
or alpha 0 you use the simulator to tell
you which actions are illegal it's not
necessarily it learns the rule of the
game as the rules but you're right in
that it learns how to play the game in a
way right it learns the good strategies
of the game without ever having theme
humans play and then mu zero doesn't
even have the simulator at hand
it just it needs to kind of come up with
its own and I I agree with the commenter
here that I think something like mu zero
is an extremely important
building block that we have in our
disposal it I feel it's still it's still
not fully enough because in mu zero you
still do this exploration by simply
basically by randomness so you have like
some exploration constant in there where
every now and then you try something new
whereas I think what humans do is they
have a model of the world and then they
deliberately explore certain parts they
deliberately form hypotheses of spaces
they don't know yet and they
deliberately try to explore those spaces
and that's maybe something more like
they'd like dreamer or things like this
or like when when we discussed with Hari
when he says you have like an explicit
exploration component in in a model they
feel it's not all the way there but I
think something like mu zero where you
learn a model of the world and you use
that model to plan ahead
I feel that's that's it that's a giant
thing and honestly I think that is
intent in innately connected to your
ability to navigate in to and 3d in my
mind whenever I plan in my head it's
almost like you're navigating some
landscape right it's the same
terminology like oh I can get from there
to there and then I can't get from there
to there like this planning logic and
navigation all seems to be the same
component in your brain and I feel
that AI systems might want to use that
fact aggregation planning logic all the
same
would you use any of those things when
you are solving the AARC challenge would
you use your imagination I probably not
I probably never gonna start because
it's a big task well remember we had a
discussion the other week Yannick where
you said that you could verbalize what
was going on in your system one if if I
had enough time yes coming back to the
reddit thing one one thing he or she
said was that generalization has a
pretty low return on investment and I
would argue that because I think the
person is implying that we don't have
generalization because clearly if it had
value we would have done it that I I
think we haven't done it because we
can't do it and if we could do it it
would have even more value yeah just
like just look at for how much IBM sold
what was their thing that that one
jeopardy
Watson that thing was entirely useless
right it could not generalize at all but
they made like this huge business case
out of it and people were throwing money
at it until they realized it couldn't do
anything but the promise was basically
generalization the promise of Watson was
you you know this thing you can just
feed in all of your company documents
and in magic right like triple your
returns and stuff and people were paying
for it until
actually they realized it doesn't do
that though eaters yeah I think it's
more along the lines what you're saying
and that it has value we just haven't
done it yet
also just local generalization is like
being able to ask the question in a
slightly different way like this idea
that you can search through your company
documents with natural questions is like
this local generalization means you get
to ask it in a you know in a non perfect
way yeah yeah but already that was so
valuable right right so hybrid rxm says
disclaimer I skimmed the paper and still
have to read it in full I mean to be
honest it's a monster of a paper it's
one of the most dense scary paper thing
it's not like it's difficult to
understand but there's just so much
information packed in there I've
personally been trying to make a video
about this shawl a paper for about the
last two months and it's one of those
things that if you don't deconstruct it
into very small manageable chunks even
even Lightspeed Jannik kilcher and this
is this is a guy who can deconstruct and
consolidate a paper in his mind and just
off-the-cuff do an entire thing on it
even Yannick had to break it down into a
three part circuits who captured bullet
points about it so it's probably the
only paper which has defeated Yannick
but anyway the AIC competition was short
and no new model seemed dominant and
arguably enforced to trial and error
brute-force search so what did we learn
from the AIC challenge dunno I guess
that we are not able to do these kinds
of things yet I mean the entire point of
a RC is that a human can do it like
almost any human can do it right that's
that's the entire point and machines
can't
I think that's that simply pointing this
out there hey there is this task right
here and it's so easy that any human is
able to do almost perfectly well on it
but the machines just suck
I know yes sort of in the last few years
we've maybe gotten a little cocky in
that we think you know with deep
learning in all we know but we were
challenging the humans on pretty much
all fronts but this shows that it's
something like uber simple is sip still
out of reach yeah well the person then
goes on to say you know what groups on
research labs are seriously engaging
with the AR C dataset why why not no
one's engaging with it and Sciales
points is that weird we are barking up
the wrong tree with these skill-based
alphago type systems are there any big
names on the leaderboard
I don't know it's really okay an iced
Cuba is in first position
nice good job Ice Cube er Oh for real I
mean if you know there seems to be two
there seemed to be lots of people of
course the question is how good is 0.79
I
look if you go to the notebooks you can
get a good
so cellular automata so cellular
automata that so this has been updated
four hundred and twenty eight times so
this appears to be where the center of
gravity is shall we say here is the
video of a cellular automata colorizing
the bars in the order of their size
okay nice
okay
and it's a wall of text it will text
well this is quite cool so okay I mean I
guess we know about cellular automata
but to make them into a language of
reasoning that seems pretty cool oh I'll
check this out after this is over
definitely
so domain-specific languages and genetic
algorithms decision trees for a RC I
would imagine they didn't get much
traction a basic CNN approach I mean
honestly it looks like people are just
scratching around here I mean there's
waiting for the Alex net moment of a RC
yeah I think it's fair to say that if
that is not going to work out very well
for those folks I guess no no serious
lab is involved in this it's the author
that is the that is the answer so we can
just finish on the hybrid rxn it seems
like there are two philosophies to
better generalization so scale-up GPT on
the pre train then transfer or develop
better inductive biases so graph neural
networks or trialist eum's
programs synthesis search methods etc
might have missed in this paper but
curious to hear a modern take on what
Chalet thinks of feasibility and
trade-offs of existing approaches
especially with new advances so big
transfer gb t3 plan to explore if the
goal is task agnostic generalization
given the results from the challenge for
instance it seems like self supervised
learning is here to stay computer vision
IRL and NLP yeah I think it's back to
its it's gonna be way easier to scale up
DBT 3 than it is to find more inductive
biases that's my take yeah probably but
I guess the question then becomes what
do you scale it up on the point of a or
C is that you don't have a dataset right
do you guys know about program synthesis
because although ml 0 comes closest to
what we know I know very little yeah
well well back really quickly back on
this idea of building a generative model
from only three examples maybe it's back
to our idea of like the curriculum
learning poet stepping-stone kind of
idea where like once we learn to
generate from like maybe the idea of
learning to build a generative model
from like three examples as a process of
going from like separates like with C
far 10 with 50,000 examples we can
easily build the generative model it's
all I mean it's so much higher
resolution than the AR C is
but it's like so maybe it's like the
stepping stones that you got to go from
generating this distribution now
generate this distribution right because
the problem here is as well it's not
like the even though it's the grids are
relatively small the set of grids that
conceivably appear in these tasks is so
tiny and so specific to humans right
it's so human specific it's not like you
can write down how to how to get there
and then if you do something like poet I
mean you know that the issue with poet
is you never know where it ends up and
it's for sure not going to end up at a
human specific thing right so that yeah
trying to compare like the really
complex terrain it walks on to yeah Jen
generating the a RC corpus it's like how
would you connect like being able to
generate an Atari game to the proc Jen
benchmark where you because the Atari to
Atari game has a lot more variance than
the proc Jen where they still have this
kind of underlying distribution but
they're these rules that are causing it
to be like a different orientation of
the maze it's like imagine going from
you can generate proc Jen levels to
generate a new Atari game and then do
all these different things you can
generate to get to a RC the thing with
the proc Jen is that there is an
underlying rule right there is a there
and it's simple enough such that a human
had to sit down and program it right if
you think about generate a new Atari
game not not like a new version of
pac-man
then you can do but a new Atari game a
58th Atari game there is no rule that
you could feasibly write down in less
than 10,000 pages that describes how
humans went about constructing the first
57 Atari games right that it that simply
that's that's what I'm that's that's my
like current point from earlier if you
could write that down you'd have already
solved the task right the entire the
entire thing about prog Chen I feel is
to reverse-engineer the rule
if you wanted to if not if you wanted to
solve but if you wanted to construct
these environments to reverse-engineer
the rule that makes these environments
well I think they're all trying to
reverse engineer like what's generating
the data right it's just it but like
even if they can't write it down they're
storing it implicitly in the parameters
yes but the hardness of being able to
learn such a thing is probably as hard
as to write down the rule that generates
it
but then I'm thinking about like these
high dimensional spaces and that's the
whole problem behind writing it down
right is the fact that it's high yeah
well it's not it's it's not high damage
if it can be high dimensional if it was
generated by a simple rule then maybe as
high dimensional as you want right but
the fact is we don't know we if you can
tell me the rule why the humans may how
the humans made these Atari games and
why they made these 57 Atari games right
and not other Atari games how they
decided on these 57 if you can write
down that rule I can easily make a
generator that generates a 58 but you
can't write but yeah but so I guess my
question is can you learn that rule from
the data yeah and I guess you can't if
you just have 57 training samples with
current methods you probably can't
so yeah so is it an issue of model
capacity or is it an issue is it or is
it an issue we need two thousand Atari
games yeah that's it that's a
complicated question I have no idea I
didn't know I mean there's if we come
back full loop to Sholay shall they
would say either you build in better
Pryor's meaning that you have a better
idea of what the rule of generation is
or you give more experience meaning you
have more data points you can achieve
you can achieve both ways
right so I like thinking about this
object permanence prior as being stored
in the parameters of the neural network
because then it's easier to transfer it
but I definitely like these generative
models like this idea like game Dan it's
really exciting the idea that you could
put like the open AI gym suite into
generative models like we I don't know
exactly how many tasks are in the open
AI gym benchmark but like could you put
all of those tasks into a single
generative model and then just condition
them with like a normalization layer to
produce a different like you know like
condition it so now it puts out carpol
balancing and condition it so it comes
out bipedal walking I have no idea
I haven't read the game can paper yaddam
I'd imagine it's like a capacity issue
like I think game can if it just scaled
it up could easily put the pac-man game
in there by memorizing it oh well yeah
by memorized but you you think something
that like generalizes and whatnot I feel
like the generalization is just the
product of like a ton of regularization
like if we dropout paths like crazy and
then we augment the data it's like
that's to me where the generalization
comes from it's conceivable I mean that
would amount to the priors you build in
right the that you say okay drop out is
a form of a prior mm-hmm what are your
final takes on Chalet I think it's a
noble attempt at defining intelligence
and making an intelligence benchmark I
think that in some ways this attempt has
failed because they're not smarter after
this and
audience remains something where the
only way to define it is I know when I
see it
it just it just remains or because
either you can't measure the quantities
that he's proposing or if you go to
something like the ark challenge I
seriously doubt that for example he has
listed all of the priors that go into it
and I seriously doubt that when the ark
challenge is solved that anyone would be
convinced that this is has anything to
do with intelligence and I I think it
will remain the I know it when I see it
and lastly I think this this criticism
of deep learning as or generally machine
learning as oh it's just skill and it's
not real intelligence it's true but I
think it's the wrong way of thinking
it's sort of the wrong way of thinking
about it and that I think something like
alphago is incredibly smart if you
factor in the people and I don't mean
this in the way that Sholay says will
it's just the people program no I mean
the the symbiosis the generalization
capability of the deep mind team plus
the computers they have is immense yeah
I say so you're saying that we we should
see them as one whole yeah I think that
process in terms of generalization
capability if we're looking at that that
symbiosis is there is one of the most
generalization capable that we have and
you can't go measure this with any kind
of psycho metrics or anything
you think at university they should
teach hütter and lakes definition of
intelligence or chalets well probably
neither is like this paper a lot but I
think are any practical purposes it's
like a nice academic exercise but I I
doubt this as any this has any
consequential but even practical
applications but I don't this has any
consequences at all well I like this
function of life priors experience
generalization difficulty I think that
is the useful way of thinking about any
of these problems I mean personally I
love his formalism it makes perfect
sense to me and it's almost as if he's
trying to be a contrarian at saying the
emperor has got no clothes right he's
saying that all of these folks are
working on AI systems that are not
really intelligent I think if that was
his aim I think it's been a success so
far contrary and I absolutely respect
the attempt to be a contrarian my one
issue is with like I I think the
superglue benchmark is pretty good even
though you know the structure of the
task and I don't understand why he likes
the animal AI Olympics more so than
superglue but just because you know all
the tests beforehand I I don't know but
I like super glue compare like comparing
it he says like super glue is awful and
animal a Olympics is awesome and I don't
know if I think yeah and similarly yet
all of these things similarly coffee cup
is awesome while alpha though is not
awesome I see no difference do you guys
think that we are fundamentally going in
the right direction on AI research I'm
quite cynical like shillelagh I think
that in in many ways we're wasting our
time are you thinking about in context
learning with gbg3 now well it's it's a
similar thing it's actually analogous to
what Chalet is saying about deep
learning being glorified hash tables GPT
3 is a very very clever hash table
interpolation machine I don't think it's
cynical because it's incredibly useful
the utility of this is incredible
it's almost like a new type of database
only you can query it using natural
language and it can reconstruct whatever
you need it to it's very powerful but is
it intelligent well but rather than
asking that I would say humans as a
result of developing the kind of AI that
we're developing have gotten so much
smarter have a phone and with the phone
I am a hundred times smarter than
without the phone right so am I'm not
more intelligent than before the phone
apparently according to the all of these
definitions isn't intelligent by itself
but I with the phone I can outsmart
anyone so I think we're very much going
into the correct actually even a better
direction than a GI because a GI is like
going to singularity and we're at
becoming obsolete the way we're
developing a yeah is that we make
ourselves so much smarter that's super
interesting cuz in philosophy that's
known as the extended mind so your your
phone and your and the Internet is an
extension to your mind and you can
access this wealth of information but if
you think about the growth of capability
it must be limited so now you have all
of this information at your fingertips
all of the information the world has
ever known and what it does is it makes
you more efficient at achieving certain
things in certain situations but yes as
you read that a vaster but but as you
improve that efficiency it kind of
levels off doesn't it well I'm not but I
get sure we're anywhere close to the end
like Elon Musk would say you know here
you bandwidth between you and the
knowledge of the world is limited by two
thumbs
and that's you know that's a pretty big
bottleneck right there
that we are still we can still lift
that's it because GPT three I think is
the pinnacle of information efficiency
through text when we have something like
a neural interface I take your point
that we might as a civilization take our
capability to the next level but for now
the limitation is something like GPT
three the GPT three allows us to ask any
question and almost immediately search
all the information in existence and get
the answer we have like two hundred
thousand GPU cluster yes how long can I
lie can ask Google like has anyone tried
data augmentation on the discriminator
and Gann training you know questions
like this that ask you questions like
that I would be able to iterate on my
research ideas a lot faster so I think
we can generalize to these kinds of
questions they want done neural
architecture search on normalization
layers if you can ask it that kind of
question right yeah well that's really
interesting because what we're saying
here is as individuals and as
collectives we iterate there's a lot of
redundancy and the iteration cycles are
quite long because we have to we have to
do research and we have to find
information and so on and those
iteration cycles will be getting more
and more efficient the velocity will
increase I guess I'm just I'm asking
there must be some limit to this so with
technology we will increase our velocity
to a certain point limited power and
when the velocity is going at maximum is
going as fast as we can will we reach
some kind of escape velocity will we
develop some kind of super artificial
intelligence or will we develop some
kind of technology that catapults us
into the future or will we saturate what
we can discover yeah good question but I
I don't know I don't want to speculate
that the optimist optimist to me says at
least for now we
can accelerate quite a bit and that's
gonna be my lifetime and it's gonna be
fun well I think Chalet would say that
and you're already going at Lightspeed
Yannick so you personally couldn't
accelerate any faster
honestly I've really struggled with this
I've been reading this paper for a long
time it's dense there's a lot of stuff
in there I'm going back and forth
because it really resonates with me what
surely is say I think he's one of the
best critics of deep learning in in his
book deep learning with Python there's a
whole chapter in there on the
limitations of deep learning and many
years ago he articulated a lot of this
stuff and of course he's developed it
further since then but I don't I don't
think he's saying that there isn't
utility to deep learning I think he's
just saying that a lot of people don't
understand its limitations that means we
can sell it much more effectively
exactly anyway on that bombshell it's
been emotional it's been great
we'll see you next week thank you seer
folks remember to Like comment and
subscribe we love reading your comments